(audience applauds)
- Oh my gosh, everybody
looks so cute today.
Look at those boots, what?
- [Maggie] Wow, thank
you, I brought you roses.
- [Kelly] You did?
- I brought you roses, no, these.
- I like it, I know.
You'd say that's so beautiful.
- This is a great couch,
I'm honored to be in between you two.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
No, I'm excited to have you on the show.
(audience applauds)
Thank you so much for taking the time.
- Thanks for having
me, it's my first time.
- So wait, is it true that
you fought through a fever,
in a very important audition?
- Yeah, I mean, my first U.S. movie
was "Mission Impossible Three".
And I flew here from Asia and...
- That was your first movie?
- That's what Tom cruise said.
(audience and Maggie laugh)
- I was like, "Geez, what?"
- I got here and then the jet lag sort of,
hits you at about 3:30,
when you fly from that side of the world.
I was living on that side
of the world at the time.
And so, of course they
called me in the morning
and said, "Your audition's at 3:30".
I'm like, "Oh no, oh God".
And then when I woke up,
I had a raging fever.
And then so, I sort of went to Paramount
and this casting director,
who I'll never forget
was so kind to me and just sort of,
like said, "Maggie, I
need you to be normal
for 10 minutes".
- [Kelly] Normal.
(Kelly laughs)
- You know, just 10 minutes
and your life will be changed.
- Yeah.
- But I went from, I mean,
I was shaking like this.
I was like, and my tea
was spilling all over me
and then I got hot and sweaty.
And so, this was happening
throughout the audition,
but I just sort of,
sucked it up and I did it
and the rest is history.
- [Kelly] Wow, congratulations,
"Mission Impossible".
(Maggie and audience laugh)
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] I was like, "That's amazing".
- [Maggie] Sometimes
you have to suck it up.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Maggie] Yeah.
No one cares how you're feeling, right?
- No, no one cares.
- You know this, you're
on camera all the time.
You can't have a bad day.
I mean, no one cares, no
one's going to be like...
- [Kelly] Well in their defense...
- "You know, Katie
Couric's having a bad day
that's why she..."
- Yeah well, and they do
that like in shows too.
Like, I was so bad because it's like,
you try and give your
best because it's like,
this is their one time to see you.
Like, that's why yeah,
you try, sometimes...
- And it's, the only
impression you're going to get.
It was either like, she was forgettable
or like, maybe there's something here.
(Kelly and Maggie laugh)
- [Kelly] So, it's so in concrete.
Oh my God. I'm stressed out.
Oh wait, so your new
show is called "Pivoting.
- [Maggie] Yes.
- So, tell us about it and
tell us about your character.
- I'm so excited because
I'm doing a comedy,
which is so fun and just, I've never,
no one's ever cast me in a comedy.
I mean, I did movies where I
had comedic elements in them,
but never really trusted
me to like lead a project,
with other funny women.
- That's exciting for an actor
to get to do like different things, yeah.
- I go to work, I laugh all day,
I love my co-stars, I love our
writers, I love our creator.
We just, we have such
a good time together.
And then I go home,
because I've done action
movies, my whole life.
And I feel like, that's pretty much
the relationship right there.
That look on my face.
- I love the chic moment.
- Yeah.
(Maggie laughs)
I go home and I feel
like I didn't even work,
because normally I'm like sore or...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, I mean, I have to have
some kind of like ailment,
because of the action I'm doing.
- [Kelly] You've got beaten up.
- I've gotten beaten up.
- Is there anything like, because
of the title of your show,
is there anywhere you feel like you,
maybe should have pivoted
in life or you did pivot?
That was like, really good.
- Oh gosh.
Now, I don't have an
addiction to shopping,
it's not an addiction.
- Now when you lead with that,
you might have a problem.
(Maggie laughs)
When you lead with, I
don't have a problem, but.
- Yeah, she doubts the
protest too much, yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
So, I just sort of,
you know, you notice
when the boxes arrive.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
- [Maggie] And you just go,
"Well, that's interesting".
Because I'm having boxes arrive more times
than I should, right?
But it, it's too much of it.
And I kind of realized I just went,
"Well, something's wrong with me".
Obviously, something's wrong with me.
So I said, "I'm going to
stop this for a month".
A month, I'm just going to,
I'm going to see cute
stuff and I don't want it.
I'm just not going to do it.
And then I failed, last
week and I bought one thing
and now I have to start
over because I'm not a liar.
I don't lie.
Like, if I have a goal.
- Okay, yeah.
- And I don't meet it, I'll start over.
I'm not going to pretend it
didn't happen, it happened.
- [Kelly] Oh, I can't do that either.
- I failed.
- [Kelly] Because that's
not winning, yeah.
- No, that's not winning, yeah.
And you can't lie to yourself.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Thoughts watching, whatever.
- But I think it's really easy,
when you're shopping online,
I notice that I accidentally...
- [Kelly] It's a click away.
- Get two of everything.
- [Maggie] Me too, accidentally.
- How does this happen?
(audience laughs)
It literally just happened to me.
- What didn't I check on this form that,
you know it's terrible.
- [Maggie] There's no consequence either.
- This happens all the
time, the quantity thing.
- [Maggie] The quantity thing.
- The quantity thing.
I'm like, "I didn't order two tea makers,
Why do I need two tea
makers? Why would I do that?"
- They don't want you to
send it back, it's a scam.
- [Katie] I don't even know I ordered two,
until they arrive and I'm like,
"How come I have two of them?"
- You know what? They get me too.
Because when I do the quantity thing,
then I end up giving it to someone,
I'm just like, "Here, I just got extra".
- It happened to me last week
with salt and pepper shakers.
I got two and I went, "Here you go, Mom".
- That happened to me with
my Lululemon tennis skirt.
(Katie and audience laugh)
- [Kelly] We are the
suckers, we are suckers.
We're falling for it.
- We are.
- [Kelly] I know, I know,
- Dammit.
- All right, everybody time
for another quick break.
But Maggie's show is called "Pivoting",
you have to watch it.
It's Thursdays on Fox.
(audience applauds)
We should also mention Maggie has a line
of environmentally-friendly,
athletic wear,
which I'm very into, called, Qeep Up.
Qeep Up, with a Q,
because Maggie Q because she's adorable
and it's an awesome idea.
I thought that was so cute.
You can look for it online, everybody
and buy doubles, everybody does.
(Kelly laughs)